en los próximos días war es el gobierno
de manuel macrón debe presentar un nuevo
gabinete tras la debacle electoral de
este domingo en las legislativas eso
también porque tres de sus ministras no
fueron electas en las circunscripciones
donde competían por eso de manuel macro
no se reunió hoy con su primera ministra
lisa bet born que está en una situación
muy delicada primero porque le costó
mucho ser electa ayer en su
circunscripción de calvados en normandía
pero también porque ella es una
tecnócrata y lo que necesitaba en el
gobierno es una persona negociadora que
consiga mayorías se especula además que
el gobierno de macrón se va a acercar a
la derecha sin embargo el isa de bonn es
una política que viene del partido
socialista pese a ello el partido de los
republicanos en la derecha ha dicho ya
que no le interesa ninguna alianza por
ahora con el gobierno de macrón mientras
en la oposición de izquierda en la nube
y de luisiana son o en la extrema
derecha marine le pen se disputan el
lugar de primera fuerza política de
oposición al gobierno ambos se la
adjudican y ambos han pedido también la
presidencia de la comisión de finanzas
de la cámara de diputado que es un lugar
desde el que se puede controlar muy bien
el trabajo de un gobierno marie le pen
ha batido un récord 89 diputados por lo
que ha decidido dejar la presidencia de
su partido y asumir la presidencia de su
grupo parlamentario y pavimentando el
camino de cara a las elecciones del 2027
en la izquierda de la nación y su
partido la france sumisa han decido
presentar el 5 de julio próximo una
moción de censura en contra de elisabeth
von la primera ministra el día que ella
presenta su programa de política general
nunca excepto 1962 una moción como ésta
ha sido aprobada en francia esta tampoco
tiene posibilidades de prosperar sin
embargo según el partido de izquierda es
una manera de mostrar el descontento con
el gobierno de manuel matrón